[The must-watch TED Talks of 2016]
[Sam Harris: Can we build AI
without losing control over it?]
At a certain point,
we will build machines
that are smarter than we are.
And once we have machines
that are smarter than we are,
they will begin to improve themselves.
We're in the process
of building some sort of god.
Now would be a good time
to make sure it's a god we can live with.
[Jennifer Kahn: Gene editing
can wipe out mosquitoes forever]
Gene drives have risks,
and those need to be discussed.
But malaria exists now
and kills 1,000 people a day.
Remember that.
It can be frightening to act,
but sometimes, not acting is worse.
[Jamila Raqib: The secret
to effective nonviolent resistance]
We're not going to end war
by telling people
that violence is morally wrong.
Instead, we must offer them a tool
that's at least as powerful
and as effective as violence.
[Alexander Betts: Here's how
we can fix the refugee system]
Rather than seeing refugees
as inevitably dependent
upon humanitarian assistance,
we need to provide them
with opportunities for human flourishing.
[Adam Foss: A prosecutor's vision for justice]
Every day, thousands of times a day,
prosecutors around the United States
wield power so great
that it can bring about catastrophe
as quickly as it can bring about
opportunity, intervention, support
and yes, even love.
[Dalia Mogahed: What do you think
when you look at me?]
What will you choose
at this time of fear and bigotry?
Will you play it safe?
Or will you join those who say,
"We are better than that?"
[Tim Urban: Inside the mind
of a procrastinator]
Both brains have a Rational
Decision-Maker in them,
but the procrastinator's brain
also has an Instant Gratification Monkey.
Now, what does this mean
for the procrastinator?
Well, it means everything's fine,
until this happens.
[Allan Adams: The discovery
of gravitational waves]
Two black holes,
the densest thing in the universe,
one with a mass of 29 Suns
and one with a mass of 36 Suns,
whirling around each other
100 times per second before they collide.
And we know it because we heard it.
[Kenneth Lacovara: Hunting for dinosaurs
showed me our place in the universe]
Why study the ancient past?
Because it gives us perspective.
The dinosaurs died
in the world's fifth mass extinction,
snuffed out in a cosmic accident
through no fault of their own.
They didn't have a choice.
We, on the other hand, do have a choice.
[Camille A. Brown: The visual
history of social dance]
Why do we dance?
To move, to let loose, to express.
Why do we dance together?
To heal, to remember,
to say: "We speak a common language.
We exist, and we are free."
[Check out the playlist at:
go.ted.com/2016]